this show it's brought to you by the gay
ship that's my new favorite way to say
yes ship is that is that Russian or
Ukrainian that's you're not an extra in
Russian doll I'm pretty sure ship the
number one finance app in the App Store
I'm really bad an accent and I just had
a madness about it you know the cash app
because it's the easiest way to send
money to your friends and you know this
man but cash app does way more than that
cash app also comes with a cash card a
free debit card that comes with boosts
which are like instant rewards for
shopping at the places that you already
love you can get up to ten percent off
your entire purchase at door - and even
safe every time you shop at Whole Foods
Target and more check out this mug I
have from the cash app because it's the
easiest way to try and grow your money
with their new investing feature on like
investing tools that force you to buy
entire stairs of shocked stock patterns
entire stairs of shocked shares of stock
come on cash app lets you instantly
invest as little or as much as you want
how nice is that this will help you
still own a piece of any stock with just
how many dollars one dollar that's wild
brokerage services are provided by the
cash app investing a subsidiary of
square and member say it
yes I PC I'm also excited to be working
with the cash app to support one of my
favorite organizations it's called The
Trevor Project you sign up for the cash
app use the promo code
Whitney not only want to instantly
receive $10 at the cash app will also
donate $10 to The Trevor Project hose
provides crisis intervention and suicide
prevention services to people like
Benton and youth across America you
can't say that
[Music]
we're coming to you during the holidays
ah the holidays you ready are you ready
I'm ready I love the holidays we put
some questions out there to y'all some
cues to use about I put questions on
Instagram I read them y'all wanted us to
tell you about how to survive the
holidays with your toxic family I know
my demo I know my demo broke it that's
my demo the broken toys follow me I
first wanted to real quick address the
controversy around holiday songs that
are people are trying to cancel dad I
shan't I shan't with this bullshit if
you cancel the holidays on a couple of
them okay trash to me yeah which ones
they're canceling maybe it's called
that's baby it's cold outside on baby
it's cold outside and I shan't you see
the precedent what's the problem problem
with baby I'm cold outside is that she's
trying to go she got Jeff the leaf okay
she said I'm an illegal and he's like
well stay for one more drink that's
called flirting they're flirting but she
says that she has to go and he says but
maybe one more drink it's cold outside
yeah they're still flirting and it is
cold outside but she does I don't think
she knows therefore I think she said
hard boundaries that she has to go what
do you think he's just trying to keep
her safe cuz how bad is it snowing but
should get killed if she didn't have
galoshes and she's gonna get out there
and just that's it I think he's helping
an uptight woman have fun I mean it's
not like yeah there it is though they
pulled the lyrics up so what's the
problem everyone's worried that people
are like he's trying to date rape her
maybe half a drink more is it that one
put some records on why I don't really
I'm sorry do you think she can say no if
she wants that's the thing he's getting
her drunk that's the part they don't
this is what I don't like I don't like
the fact that now flirting has been
turned into harassment cuz here's the
thing if I'm in my head she's four
minutes of flirting so she said no four
minutes I know
she might be harassment at that point no
I have to go you think she's a quitter
make me make me stay he's cute it's
flirting if he's ugly and harassment say
it why I said it first of all how did
you get there to begin with
where who she's obviously at his house
or someplace I mean that doesn't mean I
mean that doesn't mean it you're missing
the point
I'm not missing the point my point is we
didn't know where they are the point is
you can't cancel Christmas songs the
only reason Christmas songs are good is
because we know the melody and we've
heard them and they're nostalgic you
can't just make Shaco also what kind of
nerds are actually listening to the
music lyrics get away what's the other
one people are mad about Mariah Carey
all I want for Christmas is you who
cares what's the problem it's a bang
they're saying that she only yo it's a
it slaps
she only they're saying that she only
wants a man for Christmas and that's
Nick that's all my carry first of all I
never said it's a man and also even
could sing it what if a man son that's
not would it be feminist oh yeah they
would think it was romantic maybe yeah
John Legend's tongue that that's right
maybe a bang bang I don't like it
because it's like is this a woman
actually does isn't materialistic then
she's revolving her life around a man
she's what succubus would it be worse if
she was like all I want for Christmas is
an Hermes bag and some Louie Vuitton
sneakers and like that'd be trash too
I think we should go back to all him for
Christmas my two front teeth that's a
southern classic and there's one more
people are mad about which his grandma
got run over by a reindeer which she
should've been the fucking Road you know
the road bitch it's funny it's funny and
also reindeer they're like it's violence
against women reindeer don't see gender
reindeer reindeer don't see anything I
don't think they're blood they're blonde
listen more people get killed by deer
than crocodiles bears combined did you
know that I didn't know that that's true
I did the research for year ago this
morning we need to start a segment
called Benton's coroner it's holiday
time a lot of people to get to the point
are asking about how to survive toxic
family environments and stop looking at
your nails I'm 9 what are you what else
is there to do besides you weren't
looking at me flowers it's relaxing its
joins me nuts you look at your nails
while
talking are you bored well I was just I
thought this was a good post and to come
back some relationships go I need to I
need the notes now I was waiting I was
active listening if I look at you I get
distracted you guys here's my number one
piece of advice for going home to toxic
hassles or just any household which is
you gotta set boundaries I am bad at a
lot of things not boundaries not I got a
black belt in boundaries that's my shit
I'm a boundary to ass bitch okay when
you go home for the holidays number one
piece of advice you tell them the window
of time you're gonna be there in advance
you don't just go for the day what are
you insane you say I would love to come
12:00 to 4:00 good you set the window
ahead of time so that they know that
you're not gonna be there oh that's
smart
yeah the heart out that's really smart I
just leave they're like are you leaving
I'm like I'm done now no the problem is
that if you don't give them a window in
advance then you're negotiating we don't
leave why are you leaving you can't
leave for you like an asshole like me
that's right you got to tell them ahead
of time you know where is if you give
them a window of time and you stay 15
minutes over that you're a hero now oh
yeah you're the nicest person around
that's a good point
don't do this they don't do is I have
the opposite problem mine I just leave
and they're like where are you going
have you open gifts yet nothing but I'm
done you got to tell him a window okay
more than that
staying at someone's house all day that
is a math problem no psychiatrist can
solve that is like y equals MX plus
family trauma plus high expectations
plus people spending money plus guilt /
guilt squared it's really rough
ancestral shame equals Ron is going to
snap mine he needs to take his divorce
out on somebody you know you you have to
control where your body is that's the
only thing you can control right we say
in program like you
can only control what's inside your
hula-hoop you can't control everything
else you got to get out of there before
everyone gets wasted and before everyone
starts talking about politics see I I
agree with that I agree you can only
control yourself my mom always says my
big thing going to holidays is my mom so
my whole life you can't unring a bell so
don't say anything you can't take back
and you can't expect people to have the
same heart issue so don't get upset they
don't believe the same way you do it's
for whole dinner for everyone not for
you but just don't engage just don't say
anything just you know I I think
especially with politics like my new
thing is ahead of time I'm gonna tell
people I'm not talking about politics
when I go to something now I'll go hey
just a heads up I'm trying to not talk
about politics over the holidays just
because it's too stressful for me so if
I walk away from a conversation out of
nowhere nothing personal so yeah such a
polite family if you've seen that text
I'd be like what's wrong with you why
are you telling me this I just think we
have to also embrace people that are we
have to be okay with people being crazy
what we do is we inspect people are
crazy all year and we expect on
Christmas that all of a sudden their
neurology is magically gonna change
because there's some pretty cookies
around and that's not how neurology
works they're not so they're not crazy
we're all crazy you are crazy just you
you can't go into the holidays thinking
you're better than your family
that's just show up being there like
Thrones so ignorant they're also like no
you're a problem to just in a different
city yeah I just think like the
definition of insanity we all know the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
a different result
does not go home and expect your family
members to have just gone through three
months of therapy and psychotherapy and
read every self-help book it's not gonna
happen they're the same people in
different sweaters and you just have to
radically accept them yeah and you'll be
cooking go there at the intention to see
your family and have a good time not to
fix them or to change that you can't
you're not white knighting your family
showing up like well did you guys know
that if you quit stop it stop it if
someone is wearing a sweatshirt with an
airbrush cat on it live in Florida what
they went to Florida there's that bad
congratulate them you need to lower your
expectations right especially if one of
your family members is super into it
like if one of your family members is
wearing like a Christmas sweater with
the ball being brief nipple pasty like
that's too much
they need this more than you need it let
them have it
you know I always think the best the
best thing to do is to be of service
when you go home for the holidays my
thing could just keep busy you go in the
kitchen you start you to start taking
the trash out you start washing dishes
water the tree put the Christmas gifts
and piles like makers I wish I could go
in the kitchen this out here no around
the kitchen oh yeah the women are in the
kitchen you get the hell away that's
what that's under southward okay what
happens if you try to go in the kitchen
you you get told to you get very tart
very abruptly to leave the fucking kids
hi no one wants help yeah my mom and
them are very big fans of your in the
way of friend oh you're not helping
you're causing more problems your mom
and I are the same person
I also home something happens where we
regress to being the like a child
hundred percent I go right back to high
school because I think it's something
about the pattern recognition and also
this Pavlovian thing where when you go
home all of a sudden you're back to like
your teenage self like you get less
mature yeah
like and then you're around a bunch of
people who have seen you your whole life
and they've seen the worst versions of
you yeah you go home now I'll grown
amateur an adult but they have already
cast you in a certain role so you find
yourself either conforming to the person
that they have decided you are or you
have to audition to them that you're a
new person you're a new person I can my
interests in here is that people do you
think that only happens people that
leave their hometown like if you stay in
your hometown you're more likely to just
be adjusted to that way of life because
I thought the people that have the
biggest problem to do that go back home
because I'm enjoying the time if you're
wanting to leave your hometown you have
like a something you want you wanna be
here you go back to a different place
and people that are already there have
yeah initially interesting so huh I just
I think that also your family knows
where your buttons are over 100 you know
I mean like your mom knows she's who put
them there she installed them all
something that I love that people say
and al-anon is uh it's not one thing
it's your mother but you just have to
know that going into it you got to know
it's a landmine and you've got to be
gracious and you got to not take the
bait I think that's my biggest you know
thing is don't take the bait I would
like to know how to do that let's do it
I'm the person when we come home now
people want to say like hey oh look who
it is
big-time MIDI it's mister Bollywood
I've trained my family to know though
that I'm just gonna ignore you if you do
that no I want to learn people are
scared of you because they don't know
what's going on with your gender
unapproachable charm yeah um first of
all I I cannot ignore people when I go I
would like to learn this because I do
you take the bait I don't have debate I
just I completely I mean I ignore the
bait like just to be the bait you could
be this close you can't do that I did it
but you're up let's just try it I'm
gonna show you what I would do and then
you give me company mechanism okay
all right so you're going home to your
family my big one is Hollywood that's a
big mess right I'm gonna do it I'm oh
well if it isn't the Hollywood Lib tard
no yeah I would just look away I do I
can't you do it for me you're too good
for me now yes Susan Sue's nest no you
can't do that but that's what I do is
that nothing wrong Oh product if anyone
who walks up to you and says hey Lib
toward get out of here get the fuck out
of my face Susan she's trying to be
funny
I think that's the other thing I don't
think you know how to role play people
in South because this is what Susan
would be telling me
Susan Billy hey Hollywood are you voting
different out there Hollywood you got a
little got some fruity tendencies out
there Hollywood that's it that's the
south isn't just to get your tip line
but I think that she's trying to be
funny I think that a lot of people don't
understand a lot of times when people
are mean to you they're usually trying
to be funny and they're just bombing
because a joke that doesn't land isn't
either an insult or a lie right yes a
lot of times they're just trying to be
funny and they're bombing you're right
so what should I do you do it to me okay
hey big shot I can't believe you might
find you funny out there oh wait now you
just want to do it that is actually the
one thing that I guess your whole life
you may have been funny how they get you
on the show that's what they do that's
what my family does they're always like
how did this happen I mean you are never
funny
this is so weird yeah oh it's just I
never would have seen this coming or my
family in Texas will say Jesus did it
they'll be like well thank Jesus is
watching over here I'm like Jesus didn't
do any of this I think to week I worked
really hard I earned this Jesus had
nothing to do with this
like I end up having to
fight over like trying to share credit
on my career with Jesus that's a no
that's a no win situation but I just
think you have to just laugh just laugh
they're trying to be funny hey Liv just
ask them questions that's the other
thing people that are old they're just
trying to be funny they're trying to
relate to you they're trying to make you
laugh just ask them questions put it
back on them how are you doing what's
going on with you where do you plan to
be buried
did you have a plot yet do you have
cancer time's running out
you might want to think about how you
treat people that might be a good idea
you ever thought about that your
daughter's still pregnant I just think
that we all go home with a specific set
of expectations that our family is like
trying to hurt us and we make it worse
than it is sometimes yeah and I think
our just don't go home that's my advice
yeah if you have truly bad family don't
go home but my thing is I I do want to
work on this and I agree with you that I
know that you deserve when I go home for
the holidays I do think that I want to
work better I'm being better this
because I feel better I'm being better
at this service to my family
because they want the best version of me
and I'm there being a moody little brat
you are you are bratty I am NOT bratty
do not say that I can say I'm brandy cuz
I'm in it you know they're not gonna
haha I'm so you know down-to-earth wait
but my producers are telling me we need
to introduce our guest and stop
bickering Michael Rapaport sir I'm
excited I very interesting loved him so
much
and I think it's so important to have
guests on like this because I just I
think we're at this point where people
if they disagree with each other they
just don't talk or they don't go on each
other shows are everywhere in this echo
chamber where a bunch of people that
agree with each other are doing this
circle jerk in podcasts and they're just
like agreeing like Michael sometimes I
agree with him sometimes I don't and
that's why we're good friends
yeah even well-rounded person he's just
like he says what he means he's not
pandering to anybody you don't have to
agree with him you don't have to like be
pissed off if he says something you
don't like he just like he I respect
anyone who believes what they say and
has a strong opinion even if I don't
agree Dandy's funny there's that
pre-christmas exercise
if you don't agree with everything
Michael says this is a exercise in
tolerating an opinion that it's
different than yours just like it's
funny just laughs it's very funny
Michael Rapaport get in here please
I don't are you rolling yes the reason
why I don't wear headphones is because
I'm looking at you and I could hear you
like if I was in another room and I was
a sound engineer I'd wear headphones but
like I can see you like I even if you
talked really softly I don't need the
headphone that's why I don't like when
I'm doing progress I don't wear a
headphone have you all your pockets
plugged in I think you're just with
those two but can you hear through your
headphones I don't I haven't thought
about are you hearing me through your
head it's just a prop I don't think
they're plugged in anything they're not
working so so yeah I mean but weird they
look good no this isn't a scripted show
all right don't know no exactly not
we're playing ourselves yes they're so
funny I don't know what this is I mean
no I don't really hear any I think the
idea is that what is the point of
headphones Dave you're fucking got your
your sound guy who's got headphones on
he don't know either I think they were
hearing noise canceling I get you can't
hear me but I get that they're hearing
the sound so like if I'm away from my
mic right right on the aver Chris your
goes but but I don't need them to hear
you because I hear you sometimes Rogen
though will go you need to lean in your
mic can I get that I get that has to
heard again either of us ever need to
get closer to them yeah we only need to
get over here you know like that but but
for here you know this just this so
you're gonna lean forward okay you can
even tell that I'm not speaking of them
I if I would say could you lean forward
right I don't know I would just i black
out but you got two people wearing
headphones so don't tell me but for your
vanity I mean you look good with the
headphones but you can I would say based
on my experience you know like fly
no you are without that head of hair
yeah I mean shit especially your head of
hair looks good well now I feel it makes
me feel more of like a professional shit
I don't want to fuck you up
otally it fucked me up I would have done
a complete you don't even know if you're
here with my hair I would have done like
a curl no I'm good sorry Aqua Net good
you're good you're good I'm good you
know it's all lay down you're good I
have a weird question good are we
friends
I consider you a friend I feel like
we're I feel like we don't know each
other that well no but we're close in a
weird way I I mean I don't even know you
that long but I'll just I'll inform your
viewers you know like it was about a
year and about a half ago I think that
might have been when I first met you you
know when you actually met me and you
won't remember this we met at the
Mayweather Pacquiao fight okay and I was
sitting like up front okay and you were
standing up I was not going berserk I
was having so much fun you're going
everyone was sitting down you know cause
it's kind of from what I understand you
okay I'm Jewish in the it's just Jewish
it's just Jewish in the winter duty yeah
it's Jewish Jewish man in the wind okay
well I'm like a Ricola no let me say
this well I'll say this cuz I know
you're a Stern Show fan and the fact
that Hillary Clinton had a coughing fit
on live radio the other day made me want
to embrace my public coughing because
I'm always ashamed but I'm like this
woman almost like she I know that
coughing fit well I also you've done
Howard it's it's 6:00 a.m. when all the
all the throat gels and crystallized goo
yeah the night but I've never done that
that that deep dish Howard like you know
like that full in it's like I come on
there I stir it up yeah you really do
but but but as far as friends yeah and
and meaty yes we met in passing okay I
just was like hi because I think comics
have like a vibration where even if you
don't know each other you kind of know
each other so we were like hey what's up
I wasn't even a comic at that point yeah
but you have the comic brain
right you're a comic and your bones I
think but when went about a year and
some change ago we you and I were guests
on Bert crisis podcast and and and you
and Bert were like you gotta do stand-up
you gotta understand we got there and
Bert wasn't there right for like 45
minute we waited for Bert 444 his old
fuckin pox on his show at his home and I
was like who fuck is Bert you doing here
like fuck is this guy took 45 minutes to
get there and then the motherfuckers
late 44 I was like this is cooking and I
have such I'm so I'm so like I like I'm
coming to the end of being a podcast
cast you probably get this - I'm dying
I've had it I'm in retirement I was like
I'm done podcast I was it's a fucking it
took us it's like a side job I was a
full-time podcast guest done I'm done
okay losing money all the time driving
to be a nice every other day doing other
people's progress is like jury duty
straight-up you get to ask and you're
like I know I have like two months now
this aw I got to tell him no now I match
my New Year's resolution is mine yeah
I'm fucking done I drove all the way out
here this fucking pisshole Shack you
think you spend your money a little bit
more y'see the window fucking stuff I
mean got lighting you this this is a
real sort of fake impression of what
kind of piss box you had me drive out
but I'll say but so it's always comic
and being friends I mean this how I
consider you and my wife knows is sue
cuz I've talked about you to my wife is
that you know you guys were like you got
to stand up you got to stand up you got
your stand I drove you home that day
they drove me home that day cuz I guess
and you were like you got to do you got
to do it and then you go I'm doing the
Improv lab in in in like three weeks
just come and MC for me you don't even
you don't even have to you don't have to
do any time did you could just bring me
up on stage you could do five minutes
you could do and I was like alright fuck
it fuck no I was like I matter of fact I
remember when you drove me I was like
fuck this bitch is crazy I'm not doing
fucking driving you home you had your
white driving gloves I was like we
talked about our skin stuff we talked
about like like skin
this summer like twice every summer I
remember to put on gloves and I Drive
with my gloves so that I don't age my
hand we were talking about something
stuff and I did that in front of you is
why but we could but we just have like
we they're not a sunscreen I have to
wear is gnarly we were talking like yes
I totally get it but I remember I'll say
understand it but then you text me like
yo I'm you gave me a date like whatever
the day was it's in a few weeks will you
will you open for me will um see you
didn't say open for me Sam yeah I'll do
it I'll do it and I'm thinking I'm not
fucking doing the shit and you're like
you know it's two weeks I'm reminding
you down you don't have to do it if you
don't want it but yeah but you pushed me
like and I was like I'll fuck it I'll do
it like what's the worst think I could
come with it so I can't a couple of
ideas in my head and and you it was at
the at the lab which is the safest place
it was so small so small so chill and I
like was like I'm gonna like bring
everybody up and make the little
announcement and I fucked around with
the crowd a little bit and and and you
know I tried a couple of ideas and and
and and that was like about a year about
a little bit more year and a go and then
since then I've been back in stand-up
comedy and and and the reason why I say
the fondest I talk about all I'm life
because you know to have somebody that
you you're a fan of and then you know
who sort of pushes you in a nice way to
do something that literally has become
in the last year like a whole new part
of my creative world like that I'll say
like like the fondness and the any
appreciation that I have for you so when
you say friends like I don't know what
you consider me but I'm like I like my
wife my wife is like Whitney with like
we talked about you're like what I'm
like you know when I'm on fucking tour
cuz I started touring and I'm like you
know timeless fucking bitch coming out
here and like you know where's my ten
percent but you know like I'll always
like have that you know sort of like
affinity to you for that and then like
you know when I started doing like you
just love me I have but I you know this
business you have so much comings and
goings with people and and stand-up in
particularly motherfuckers are such
haters you know
you know a lot of times we'll get jobs
as actors I never once in my head been
like who's this motherfucker on the set
oh he's a stamp like I'm yeah I'm never
like oh he's never acted like you well
some people are insecure and I be of
them are on some bullshit right but you
know for you to give me that you know
encouragement and then the follow
through and like literally like you know
push me like to do it like when you say
like you are you know like I have like
an appreciation for that like cuz you
know this business you come across so
many people for so many years and you
know it's so hard to maintain and you
have you know your own family and we all
travel and you know you're like we're
like you know it's like mini carny life
you know you're in Pittsburgh for three
months doing this show and you know it's
hard to maintain race relationship it's
like for me like just like I'll always
have that appreciation for you to push
me over off the cliff to start doing
because I adore doing it it's it's
intimidating but I get off on that keeps
you like short and voluntary response
people can't fake it to me stand-up is
like the truth like you do TV shows feel
like that was a great take you're like
alright people give comments in the
comment section they're like that was
amazing right can't trust you I can't
trust anyone's opinion whether someone
laughs and voluntarily or not like
that's true I got stroke I know where I
stand with you people that I feel the
most yeah kind of saying yes funny cuz
that night the first time you were going
on the lab that first time you've gone
on what like 20 years more than that you
were like I don't know I don't know you
went out you're so students like five
minutes you did like 20 minutes yeah
fucking around but but III love it I'm
enjoying it and I've been out and about
and you know and going all the hot spots
the buffalo Buffalo buffalo was Joe
Buffalo so I did Buffalo with no voice I
had bronchitis and I couldn't even speak
in the audience like help me out they're
good people who did the whole show I did
the whole show with bronchitis I you
know I'm so scared of I fortunately I
haven't been sick I'm so scared of doing
stand-up sick
I have something what do you got what do
you got I started bringing my own
microphone on the road it is a game
changer I take it Ben knows I bring it
with me my opener goes off puts my
microphone on nobody notices nobody sees
it and I have a fresh mic you're not
inhaling the sip
of fucking you know you know not
inhaling like all the like road pussy
off people's Chin's that hit the
microphone you're not inhaling Bobby
Lee's scrotum juice or any of that think
about what goes on with these
microphones in the road but forget the
road the fucking clubs in LA or even
nastier because it's ten minutes ten
minutes
I know if you go I mean even it's the
night before the fucking week before
it's disgusting my doctor won't even
talk to me like when I come in and I'm
sick he's just like are you doing
stand-up every night at the Comedy Store
I'm like yeah and he's like alright I'll
give you a z-pack but I cannot help you
but the most filthy thing is our cell
phone right the filthiest thing on the
police it's my own yeah that's right my
own like it's just like a circular you
know circulated shit cuz I'm germ DUP
and I got all sorts of like it's all
part of Judaism and Jewish eastcoast
jutsu specific kind of Jew dinosaur Jew
that dinosaur Jew like the dinosaur Jew
is like Bernie Sanders okay that's the
dinosaur like that's a certain kind of
Jew and again I am Jewish should to make
sure Dinah it's a certain kind of Jew
that will go extinct at a certain
alright but I'm the new era of it and
and and it's more like more like cooler
but we will morph into that like it
probably won't be with the suits but the
hair growing out of the years the random
mole with haircut whim yeah yeah and you
know and just it's phlegm that screen
top to bottom yeah yeah so have you
encountered any like won't culture
warriors don't understand it because I
feel like with what you were doing for
so long in podcasting you know like you
would say what's on your mind like so
fearless I haven't had any problems live
zero with Winnie with any like social
shit you know the only thing that kind
of like you know people perk up at is is
the Trump shit
but but other than that I haven't had I
haven't had any any real you know real
problems you know with that or any kind
of backlash or anything like that and
you know yeah I haven't you know uh you
know my my my comedy isn't isn't
it's I say fuck a lot but it's not dirty
yeah you like I yeah that guy you know
it's not it's not dirty like I say
fucking I just where I talk yeah yeah
and then and then the Trump stuff
because I hit him I hit him I like I
hate that motherfucker not and I want to
continue to hit him I I feel like you
have to hit him me I feel like I have to
but I think also you particularly I
think sometimes and like you know I was
watching an interview that you were on
that I really this is a sentiment that I
go back and forth um who's saying
everyone that has a platform needs to be
using it to be speaking right now or
else you're enabling but you are so
specifically qualified in a way because
being from New York and like running or
like knowing him so in knowing his
character yeah it's like you have a
moral imperative to share what you know
yeah and and and and because he's in New
Yorker and the way he talks you know
he's like on some deranged my cousin
Vinnie shit you know like that movie My
Cousin Vinny like he went out and the
townspeople he charmed all the small
town people Joe Pesci this is the bad
deranged devil version because these
these people that are still fucking with
him forget the policies forget the
Ukraine forget forget all the shit just
the fact that he'll make fun of his
opponents looks his wife's the wife's
looks the the Ted Cruz the Ted Cruz wife
the John McCain the dead John McCain
this ain't no fuckin president but I
think a lot of people and I've learned
this just from touring a lot a lot of
people see that as someone who's like oh
he doesn't give a fuck he's an alpha
he's not playing then neither do i Ethan
do another people get all freaked out
then those are same people like he's
your president I mean like he's my
president that has no controllers
nothing they said what you're doing I go
paint a president yeah that's right
that's right I'm not I'm not a political
person I'm Nettie I'm an actor and I'm
not even a buttoned-up that I name a
George Clooney like I'm not one of these
fucking had shaken you know uh uh you
know I'm you know I'm here for a big car
I'm just here to talk shit so yeah I'm
doing it and and yes he's doing it he's
the president I want the president to be
in more control of their of their
language and their emotions than me
cuz I know I'm fuckin nut yeah there's
also something so Teflon about him
that's fascinating because of what I did
his roast yo you did that I did his
roast did you perform a right I
performed on it it was what year was
that for real we were writing jokes
about him running for president like it
was a joke like you're such a Fame whore
you're running for president this must
have been was Joan Rivers David
Hasselhoff 2000 2011 I made fun of his
dick I went after his building saying
his buildings were trash I mean I went
so wet after Milania she was sitting
right there going after I mean just I
would you say like she's not that of us
pull it up I said Donald you're gross
nobody likes you be put back every
couple years and nobody knows why you're
like the McRib
you got Melania a huge 12 carat diamond
engagement ring you should not have
gotten for a diamond now she knows what
hard is supposed to feel like
that's cool down the middle remember
that I got to rewatch that I remember
going up to him afterwards and I cuz
when you say after at every roast you're
like hey sorry like it's just jokes or
whatever and he went it's great it's
great television you just said to me
that was great television and I just
remember being like that's such a weird
thing to say after someone just came for
your dick and your wife and your
daughter like that was great television
man it kind of sent chills down my spine
do you really remember it I remember it
like it was because I just remember gone
you weren't as biased as you are now
because no idea he was like a business
guy he was like a business guy with you
know silly hotels and team you know had
the number one TV show we forget he's a
fucking brilliant television ratings
person he knows how to get people to
watch stuff really smart shit and
afterwards he said that was great TV and
any right here I'd ever any roast I had
ever done when I did Joan Rivers I wrote
for Flavor Flav I wrote for Larry the
Cable Guy maybe Pam Anderson someone's
feelings always got hurt and the person
getting roasted always gets up there
halfway through was like okay didn't you
know you realize not everyone there's a
sociopath and they get up there they
always get their feelings hurt Carrot
Top almost cried Pam Anderson got really
upset with me and Donald Trump good
television right nothing not shaken by
anything no feelings hurt he's a
motherfuck it was wild I saw someone he
said something that he doesn't drink
he does it like like I'm like you know
like you you watch it does he speech is
like you know if you're if you're doing
stand-up or yeah even a pods averages
because you need to keep your shit moist
I watched him at one of his fucking
things where he says I watched the whole
thing and he didn't drink water he
didn't even sweat I was like this is a
fucking animal cuz you could say what
you want about him now motherfuckers an
animal animal and a beast a fucking
nasty fucking fucking beast he's an
animal so it is what it is but we don't
want to do policies I know people get
all tired of the shit
better hair better better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
Benton get it you can start
communicating under 24 hours not a
crisis line though it's not self-help
what is it it's personal counseling done
counsel oh it's professional and
personal counseling done securely online
it's a broad range of expertise in
better hips counseling network which may
not be locally available in many areas
but it's available to clients worldwide
you can log into your account anytime
you can send a message to your counselor
you get thoughtful responses this is
literally yeah it sounds great it's
therapy without having to leave your
house better Cal wants you to start
living a happier life today that's more
than I can say I do want to amp you're
alive you had a visit there website
there's testimonials so you see they
line about this would you do better help
I would try it why won't you do it
because I feel fine I think we should do
couples better huh couples backgrounds
what do you think they would tell us
just to get married already probably we
are like a divorced couple visit better
help calm slash Whitney and better heelp
and join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of experienced professionals
special offer for good for you listeners
10% off the first month that better help
calm slash Whitney that's you doesn't
your parents um pack your lunch anymore
but you still need to eat yes have your
favorite restaurants brought to you with
door - brown paper bag not included Thor
- connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city ordering is
easy
nothing's easier than this yeah you open
the door - app choose what you want to
eat and your food will be delivered to
you wherever you are not only is your
favorite pizza already on door - there's
over 340 thousand restaurants in 3300
cities it's for more than I knew there
were that's a crazy amount of cities and
a crazy amount of restaurants I know
what would you order on door dad oh I
would order Cheesecake Factory for sure
no Benton I would buy because she's a
factory it's it's just always what it is
and that's when I want I want I want
consistently good stop hitting the table
in this door - ad I like this company
50 States and Canada order from your
local go to or choose from your favorite
restaurants like
Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a and the
Cheesecake I stand corrected
don't worry about dinner let dinner come
to you right now our listeners get how
much off $5 the first order of $15 or
more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code
Whitney not Benton don't open my name in
there well Whitney $5 off your first
order when you download door - app
that's like one piece of cheesecake I'm
dead it's literally a piece of cheese
five dollars plenty more from the app
store enter your promo code quit now
don't forget promo code Whitney for five
dollars off your first order from door -
if you put in my code I get to keep
doing a podcast thank you you and I have
a really weird thing in common what is
it both had our ear bitten off you had
your ear bitten wrong yes but by a dog
all right baby I wear headphones so much
I had my ear totally bitten off yours
doesn't have any weird it does no it
doesn't oh it does how did oh there's no
cartilage or apart see mine had to get
like surgically sewn back together can
you see it
oh lady there right if you did get taken
off and split off and hanging off when
you were how old three years ago when
you were you were famous person three
years ago yeah that like disappeared for
like three months I couldn't leave my
house Oh crazy I didn't even know that
yeah yeah yours your road 19 I was
laying in a fight yeah yeah in a fight
and and and um and it was like a a bad
fight and it was it was a few of us it
was literally like some what are you
looking at shit yeah like I was my
friends were real tough guys and and and
and it was just like what do you feel it
like did you feel it I felt the bite and
it was warm yeah yeah it wouldn't know
maybe I need a lot and yeah I bled a lot
but I I couldn't feel it but I this was
like this is I was 19 it was June of
1989 no May of 1989 and I had already
made a plan like because I was look kind
of getting into trouble I'm gonna go to
Los Angeles to be a stand-up comedian I
swear to God the while he was biting
late because I like I was kind of
winning the fight but it wasn't like
winning
I don't know why your face is so close
because I
no I got like we would like get a
wrestle tussle type of thing and I got
on top of him right so he was literally
right here my arms were underneath this
body weight oh I couldn't get my and his
head was right here and he'd seen that
Holyfield fight and he notices before oh
shit and he bit my fucking ear and I
said to him you're biting my fucking ear
like there was no rules like in street
like there was rules of street fighting
but as soon as I backed up I remember
clear as they soon as I backed up I
remember going like this and I remember
thinking you can't be a stand-up
comedian no ear like I remember thinking
that trying to chop did it yeah his
shits all fucked but yeah how did you
you may have you told the story on your
I've never told this to show now so so
how did you got your idea but by a
fucking dog one of these rescues this
crazy yeah yeah it was a rosetta is that
crazy look around my god see you are so
much louder is that rescue you just
rescued with a smooch face is that dog
that dog is not here that dog is in San
Diego okay so violet who how did you get
your bit this was a dog that I'd pulled
from a shelter who was a bait dog and
what happens with a lot of these
especially in live in LA there's
pitbulls there's dogfighting those all
sorts of shit not that there's such a
thing as a pitbull I always feel the
need to say that it's not a real breed
right and so on this was a dog that I
pulled it was probably a bait dog and
taken from their mother too young so
they take all these dogs from their moms
for two young
what they do is dog's mouth is their
hands right they use it to but their mom
teaches them not to use their mouths as
their hands so this dog was taken from
its mom to young oh it was also kind of
my fault because I didn't establish
dominance properly with the dog because
I felt so bad I let the dog sleep in the
bed with me I let him lick me I let him
come sit on my lap and then one day we
were on the floor and Daisy was there
one of my other dogs who was licking my
face I were both licking my face right
you were by yourself by myself
I pushed Daisy off me right because you
always have to make sure you're keeping
DOM and it's when dogs are doing
something dominant few have big dogs
right so I push Daisy away all good I
pushed this other guy away wasn't having
it see it was so quick I truly don't I I
and it wasn't aggression I end up taken
to this aggression specialist this guy
named Brandon
who's a total badass he's a show I think
on CBS about dogs cuz I was like what do
I have to put this dog down like like I
can't like adopt this dog outright so we
did an aggression test and pitbulls
Staffies they always give you a warning
so there was no growling there was no
anything just like quick like said no
we're playing my ear I same thing happen
and then there was like a my hair got
caught in it so there was like four or
five seconds that I just kind of like
was like in slow motion then I kind of
went unconscious and then I felt weirdly
like it wasn't it didn't feel good but
it felt kind of like numb in a way that
I now know cuz I looked up you know the
girl that had her arm but not like shark
yeah she said that her arm felt like an
orgasm like they send your brain sends
endorphins and sends I I didn't have no
Year award it wasn't that should have
and so uh so it kind of felt good in a
way it's like our brains way to like
keep us fighting and I I did I've did
this and I felt like warm and I felt
like wet and I looked in the mirror
stilled into you and then finally I saw
that my ear was hanging down yo and I
was like okay and then I got really calm
and did you have to get like a surgery I
had to get a surgery I almost ran out of
time because you know cartilage it you
only have four hours till it confused
back so right they had to sew it back in
but the problem with ears is you can't
anesthetize ears because you have to put
the needle in the cartilage so he was
like it's gonna hurt so much more to
anesthetize your ear oh so you saved
your cartilage yeah so this is my this
is all my ear right I have some filler
in here like they put like Restylane or
something to kind of make it look normal
uh-huh I could still do another surgery
but I don't really give a shit but they
sewed it together and then like a month
later I went back to get like a check-up
on it and they were like oh we didn't
think it was gonna take at Cedars at
Cedars man and then I went to UCLA for
the next guy ears aren't a joke no you
came close yeah yours are in a fucking
joke what did you use to fill it in no
there is no fill in that's why there was
no car I was in a fuck I was in
Brookdale Hospital anybody from Brooklyn
they'll tell you Brooke the hospital is
not a good
yeah there's no cars no cartilage it's
like a bite it's a it's a bite you know
but today the cartilage come off no I
had to get a skin graft from back of my
ear they gave it like a little skin
graft and and that's how they you know
sort of made the skin but there was no
no nothing there was no you know like
I'm just glad that I got this shit but I
was like you know it fucked me up for a
while because I was so self-conscious of
it and I I know the guy you can't hide
it it just no you can't buy dramatic and
and I was just like you know but luckily
it worked out and I haven't gotten in
any trouble but there is something I
think when you have an injury like that
it really forms you as a person it has
an impact on you like it's a kind of
trauma it happened you as an adult
how many as an adult how many think
three years ago yeah it was crazy this
shit was one of those 19 is like a
different person
yeah I mean I was so stupid you know
when I was 19 I was so dumb but boys in
particular I think we're at our dumbest
between like 17 and like 20 well that's
like Lord of the Flies where you're
going out to sort of like figure out
where you stand in the world but you're
at your dumbest because you also think
you're at your smartest that's really
fascinating you're fucking dumb yeah
shit now because of like social media
all the dumb shit we did in secret
people are now putting on the internet
for permanent use forever yeah yeah you
know don't you imagine all the shit that
you did when you were 19 uploading it
and having employers be able to Google
it forever I mean I can't imagine being
19 like just like you know I can't even
imagine being single now at this age as
a single man like the the the they like
how you meet people like there's no like
there's no like I feel like now I mean
I'm sure it happened still but I feel
like now like the you know like when I
was a kid or you know even in my 20s and
you know then and then I was married and
I was single but the whole idea I mean
it was like a it was like a fucking
torture to go up to a woman and and I
was never good at this I kind of believe
that I'm telling you I was never good at
it I was at Siri what did you do what
was just you know my it on me let's go
let's see my feet my thing was how you
doing you know but
that was it I mean I was very nervous
how do you deal with now as a woman as
someone who like cuz you know you're
like a shit talker right my yeah you
know you talk shit yeah just just think
about like you like your sense of humor
like yeah you're like kind of a ranter
yeah you talk shit but you're also like
you know one of these people that are in
this you know Hollywood movement of you
know moving things forward you know how
do you sort of play both of those things
because like you could be a chit talk of
it then they'll be like well now you're
being you know you're complaining like
not in the saying like oh somebody you
know Donald Trump's touching your ass or
whoever but yeah that's obvious but like
just in terms of playing both sides of
it my thing is like I just you know I
know that there that a lot of people
think like I got to play a certain game
and kiss some certain ass and like you
know support this cause
my thing is I definitely do call out
like hypocrisy I don't like it you know
like in the last special I thought I was
gonna get in a lot of trouble cuz I was
like hey no one's been meaner to me in
this business than women
why is know right why is no one saying
that and I thought I was gonna get torn
apart but women really can't totally you
know cuz I think there's very few women
right now have a microphone and a lot of
women are just like alright well there's
nothing we can do you know so I didn't
realize how much people were already
thinking that I don't think I say things
that are like wildly off the grid you
know I mean like sometimes when I do
should talk about something everyone's
like yeah that's totally true so it
doesn't end up being super controversial
I got you I'm not like I don't want to
attack anybody you know but I just think
it's like a little bit crazy that
everyone is like you know like support
women in Hollywood support women in
Hollywood and like all the movies that
with you didn't go most people in
America don't care or know who directed
a movie if it's Martin Scorsese if it's
Steven Spielberg no-one's like who
directed it a woman okay let's go down
to the mall am I wrong yeah no one cares
am I wrong benches laughing am I wrong
you're not wrong it's so funny but you
just know what my aunt's not like who
directed it right I need is a woman a
few people that have cached those and
that's the thing it's just sort of like
it's like well these female directed
movie no one's going to see it people
are sexist no they're not sexist they
just don't care they're not knowing
about yours if any job and we could tell
it's not a good movie you know but I
think my point about that which
that like you know everyone's coming to
me to try to do reboots and try to do
whatever like making a female James Bond
why what to me that is not feminist at
all because the guy that created the
character is just gonna get more money
if you do a reboot on it right so if I
do a reboot of James Bond and it's
played by a woman right I have to share
screen credit with the original guy the
guy gets all the backend that created it
the guy that made the song that composer
guy he's just gonna get more money cuz I
have to use the song the most feminists
should I could do is go create a new
character where I get all of the backup
right right right right
you know like taking a brand that
already exists that a guy made a mean
like nanny nanny I'm gonna make this
ours now it just feels like it feels
like um Redskins vs. cowboys it just
feels like team I got Edition I got
native team competition and some things
just aren't good or some things just
don't resonate and it has nothing to do
with gender or something just don't
resonate yeah and and and just because
it's women or because it's a black
director or because it's or whatever the
fuck it is it just might not resonate
yeah or just might not it just might not
be popping and also right now it's like
women finally directing movies at a time
where the movie business is dramatically
changing so it's also it's like it's not
always sexism it might just be like
people are watching videos more your
songs might be wack yeah I mean I'm cool
I like that first shit just might not
but I say that sometimes to people I'm
just like I don't I'm the first to tell
you if a situation is sexist this isn't
that situation a lot of guys didn't get
their shows picked up a lot of guys move
right um - you know but 2 broke girls
that was a situation where I'm always
the first to say if something is unfair
when in pitch 2 Broke Girls ahead of a
studio a guy very famous head of a
studio went love it want to make it can
it be two boys that's a situation where
you're just like ok well that's right
but that was that she was like a little
bit ahead of where we are now like if
you if that never happened you did 2
broke girls now you'd be like this would
go like now's the time
oh really you know because now it's a
you know girl shit is yeah is is like
people are a little bit more conscious
of it yeah wanting to fill the queue
yeah but I also think we're at a time
where people don't want to be told what
to watch or
to that home no one wants homework
viewing so I actually think - Burke
girls did well then because we weren't
treating we were they were just human
beings and right and weights a good show
it's a boy it was just like funny you
know it's also it's like there's a
little bit and I know that I'm not in
trouble for this but it's like fucking I
I just I pictured to me more sitting in
her house whenever one's like women
never star in movies and she's just like
I live in a glass mansion on a cliff
because I've been starring in
blockbusters for I know she was in
bikini isn't she was sexually fucking
dude but it was Brad Pitt sexualized he
would just took it off at 53 we in like
took the shirt off because he's Brad
Pitt yeah man objectified in this
fucking objectified and and you know
men's looks are just useless yeah check
this out Johnny Depp this is a good
actor Johnny Depp is not Robert De Niro
Johnny Depp is not Daniel day-lewis he's
a good actor he thinks choices yeah and
he's I liked him in that what was the
Boston gangster movie he was good I love
that him saying but without that fucking
look without that fucking beautiful
looks Johnny Depp would not be Johnny
Depp Brad Pitt wouldn't be Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio wouldn't be Leonardo
Capital either with Paul Newman or
Marlon Brando all these people the
biggest of John F Kennedy frankly or
John Jr I mean so so it's like it's like
it kind of goes the same way like the
stars you know like Will Smith these are
all good-looking motherfuckers John
Tudor oh yeah right this is probably my
favorite actor this motherfucker never
you know he he's not that they could
well there's a character actor right
call him character writers brother
Redford yeah he's I think Robert Redford
not even a great actor he was poppin cuz
that face in those blots so I buy from
his catalog sometimes very overpriced
just look at the Robert pull it together
too expensive
you're Ottomans are just a little too
expensive for me but I just I don't I
know that I'm always gonna play devil's
advocate about someone really women
never star in shows like like I Love
Lucy is still like the biggest show in
syndication people are still what you
know I just feel like I feel like right
now there's a little bit of an
overcorrection and it's already been
shown that less people are hiring women
writers rooms cuz they just like don't
want to deal with it's just like let's
just like be grateful the idea is
equality not superiority right you know
I mean I think there's a little bit of
woke bullying and feminist bullying of
like I get to say whatever the fuck I
want and you can't say it back to me and
if you if you call me out or try to
disagree with my calling your sexist I'm
calling fucking fucking call you won't
answer it's like a cold road I what I
don't like is this idea of we're strong
women but you're not allowed to give it
back to me cuz actually we're kind of
weak too it's like well okay like if
you're saying you're so strong girl
power all that stuff you should be able
to have a conversation with someone you
disagree with I agree or that disagrees
with you I agree I know I agree so
that's where I and I think maybe it's
because all my friends are male comics
and I have to constantly fight with them
and that's crazy I know you male comics
that you're friends with male comics
that's wild but I can put you're a woman
though they're gonna be a little chiller
I don't know too much really to nuts
really man I go to do my shit and I get
the fuck out of it the actors are way
weirder to me to me comedians and
professional truth tellers and actors
are professional liars
I would rather be friends with the truth
tellers so I'm always gonna get it true
are you friends with actors I have Fred
I have a lot of actress friends I don't
think I ever let it they're fucking
nuttier than comic you thinks actresses
I'm not alone
yes you are anybody but so much yes but
yeah there's crazy people in every field
by the way it's the comedians and actors
we advertise it we go on stage and tell
everyone I'm cream and weekend we go on
podcast yes oh that's there is something
happened if you feel the need every
night to go make strangers laugh
something is off I agree you know
audible bow Banton love's all-time
favorite now it's your favorite my
favorite after my phone is the most
sincere I've ever seen yo this is yeah
this is my favorite things audible I
think everyone should have it it's great
you get to read a book without actually
having to freaking read it's the best
thing ever
yeah and some books are just better when
the person that wrote them reads them to
you it's just that it's like everyone's
traveling you're running around you're
getting gifts and you want to be able to
just listen to a book there's no time to
sit down and read a book who has that
kind of time okay think about giving the
gift of audible that's a great gift to
give people now is the best time to do
it with a special offer a fifty three
percent off your first three months
that's a crazy amount off access to
unbeatable selection of audio books
including bestsellers motivation
mysteries thrillers memoirs and more
what are you listening to um I am
currently listening to
I just finished Calypso by David Sedaris
it looks so smart over there hey
Hollywood Jamie three titles every month
one audiobook and two exclusive audible
or audible originals audible I said
audiobook I got audio Bowl you can you
know they're there
listen on any device anytime anywhere
with the audible app it's great while
commuting at the gym and during your
holiday travels it really is a genius
thing to just listen at the airport the
idea of going to the airport and
actually having to like like get a book
in your brain while you're waiting and
doing nothing yeah
best thing ever give yourself the gift
of listening and the gift of helping
someone else become smarter and being
more interesting people could listen
more I like giving but I don't know what
that means that was a dig at me and I
know it go to audible.com slash Whitney
right now for a limited time you can get
three months of audible for just 695 a
month that is more than half off the
regular price choose one audiobook and
two audible originals absolutely free am
I reading that right Brenton yeah
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
Whitney or text Whitney to 500 500
that's audible AUD ible calm slash wit
Tunis or text Whitney to 500 500 500 500
performed by um yet yes
Miami's nuts yes nuts and the shows are
always a little bit later since people
start the night later yes I was at some
place in Miami and these girls were
filming me it was like three girls and
they're filming me and I kind of just
tried to pretend it wasn't happening you
know and then it kept going and they're
like the odds thing when I was on stage
and I had another hour come out yet and
I got shit like they'll probably post it
and her know what to do and I don't have
to like get involved and have someone
text you know because then they have to
reach out to them and have them take it
down and then they get pissed and then
they tweet wouldn't get my thing down
so I just said it to them from the stage
I was like hey guys mind like not
filming and they looked at me like I was
crazy they were like oh no we're we're
just we're filming ourselves on state
with like why you were on stage I was
not in the shop right oh shit there have
a hole they were just there Instagram
laughing themselves right oh I was the
least famous person in the room right
they were the celebrity funny I was the
background of their video that's funny
it was so embarrassing they looked at me
like what do you why would we film you
yeah we're the star look at us like were
the stars I got a spray tan and all that
so crazy so I never know I am now too
embarrassed if someone's pointing a
camera at me if it's in selfie mode I
don't want to say their eyes and when
people are do I'll just be like yo
what's up look good at least get a good
picture I like that you're doing clubs
first yeah yeah I'm not come on man
that's good that's how you're gonna just
like get like you know you got over
comfortable yeah yeah yeah you got oh I
mean shit like you you you got oh you
gotta like you you have to I have to uh
yeah I'm not there's no rush also like
to just like I want to do it's so true
like do you have like a goal in mind
like do you want it like do a special
Jon like just be Mike my goal is to just
can just keep making the best shit that
I could possibly can and then the other
things if it's a special you know that
would be a good first sort of goal but I
want it I want a special to be special
they get specials to everybody and their
fucking mom now I want it like also like
I know they'll be like scrutiny like I
want the shit that's right that's right
and I want it to be top to bottom as
personal as I possibly can get
it's really smart action if it's not
personal it won't be original that's
true but but but like the only way it's
going to be special yeah and to to
resonate in somebody is if you know
beyond just being SuperDuper funny or
like Seinfeld funny yeah is is it to be
personal
me like like I have to the whole thing
has to be personal I'm not there yet
it's also so hard to get a take or a
premise into a special that no one else
has done because there's so many talk
shows there's so many like Instagram
like the shit you do on Instagram so
it's like if you're talking about
something by the time you get in a
special in eight months ten talk show
hosts have already talked about it
someone's already talked about odd cash
you know like just like oh here's
Whitney's take on a premise I hear
that's right so but if your personal
right you're not gonna go into that pile
right right I think I really needed to
hear that in this next special because I
think I've been trying so hard to not
talk about my personal life too but you
have to I know but I sometimes over
share that I'm working on but but when
you you know when you get that I don't
think it could be a whole special but
like when you get that vibration of
realness from somebody like you know
when that that genuineness and and it's
it's it's like it's painful yeah that
that is what I aspire to yeah you know
cuz I you know that's that's my goal
yeah comedian now goal with you know
like that's what I respond to with music
with films with actors yeah you know I
respond to some sort of whether it's
Gabe given to me through hip-hop through
jazz through drama or comedy the things
that resonate with me yeah are are an
expression of self yeah in sports like
athletes are certain I have higher like
were you just like you see a part of who
they are yeah it's it's it's beyond just
their greatness it's it's like like
Muhammad Ali he's the most well known
like him doing what he did in the ring
15 rounds like I'm going to die in this
ring that's beyond just being fast or
being able to punch oh that's an
expression of yourself that's art that's
a sport an expression an artistic
expression of an athlete yeah that's why
we respond to him yes
find this out show certain athletes were
you know Jordan it was a different thing
it's it's it's like he had like a like
Kobe Bryant Lee it was the same thing
but he had a mask I it's just for me
like that's what I respond to it in
creative and I need to hear that because
I think for me like especially right now
in this moment where vulnerability is
now a commodity like everyone's
competing with who can be the most
vulnerable and who can like have the
most depression and the most anxiety and
I agree I was like I need to talk about
Lyme disease awareness grew up in the
Hamptons and a bug bit me and it's my
moment to be her and the anxiety and the
fuckin depression and let me tell you
something some depression is radar give
them give them give them give them
through the you know yes no when you're
you're when you're calling yourself
depressed and OCD and schizophrenic and
psycho you are undermining the actual
people who live with depression and you
have anxiety and depression let me tell
you something this is like motherfuck
that's right you know like like why
don't you have anxiety about how boring
you are talking about your anxiety I
would be anxious boring someone to death
with my fake self diagnosis that's what
I say about my question to you but I'm
on the same shit like with these like 20
year old of course you supposed to have
anxiety because you didn't pay attention
in school you didn't go to college cap
you think shit sweet shit's not sweet
now and you're broke of course you're
anxious everyone's anxious in their 20s
you're trying to get laid you feel weird
about your body you don't have any money
you don't know where you live you know
that's not it's gonna be impression know
that but if you have anxiety that's
normal
yeah it's gonna force you to work harder
yeah if you take away anxiety I don't
want to hear about it on your society is
why we have buildings and airplanes
anxiety is what drives things because
you're in that anxiety they got cut off
the fucking 10th grade basketball team
that's how I got better thank you
anxiety you didn't even like you know
fucker Whittle up and go on his YouTube
thing under his blankets in the dark and
you could just see his eyes peeking out
he fucking got better like you fucking
get your fucking tuck you
fucking balls up you little bitch you
and fucking step up to the fucking plate
for real I am very grateful for all of
my fears all my anxieties they are their
fuel that's right it's called motivation
I think we're all so I never used that
term I'm not again you got a dislike so
oh they're making I get it there are
real anxiety there is real this is my
farewell podcast Benton is just he's
just like I'm he's applying for another
job and I have depression and I can't
what's that I have depression I can't
talk about that you have like seasonal
depression isn't yours
mine's just it just shows up sometimes
in that town it goes away
yeah you just tell it to be more like
beat it you've got like that southern
Tennessee like I'm not doing this today
yeah it's just a visitor yeah it's just
such a very um it's a very like I have
depression I'm an to antidepressants all
right cool now you're just bragging
about how much health insurance you have
I get it you know it's the president
being in jail yep that's correct they
should check the pressure on people in
jail very curious not that I've been
there but that's depressing
yeah being a roofer in the fucking
summertime yeah that's a fucking that's
something the fucking that'll make you
depressed but I don't ever want someone
to feel sorry for me I don't want
someone to ever watch my special and
like whoa she was so vulnerable
I just wanted me was fucking funny I've
got our I got you know I I think I
sometimes overcorrect cuz I never want
to lay I just want to go all the way
around the track I got you you know I
never want to have like a crutch I hear
you I never want to like use
vulnerability in a way where people
can't say the show wasn't good because
if I go on a show in a tavola I'm not
sayin vulnerable like you I'm just
saying like the Richard Pryor vulner I
see what you know I see what you mean I
I in hindsight you liked him he was so
like that was so it was so genuine you
know so I'm you felt his pain yes
correct I mean what he you can't
duplicate that no no no I mean right was
he was a vibrate it on a frequency that
was just you're on the edge of your seat
talking about catching himself on fire
and beating is why you know and stuff
like that but I think for me like I
think that if I were to get too personal
about like bad things that have happened
to me then I'm getting more credit than
I deserve
but if you make them funny that that's
what I would have to the master trick
that's right I don't want anyone to be
like ya know as much it was good but no
one can say anything because
victim writer no one's allowed it's got
to come around to being funny or else
they're a bully right now I don't like
using the fact that I'm a victim to make
someone else's opinion bullying I got
you I think I just try too hard in that
vein but um you know I don't know it's
just it's really hard to pick what to
talk about on stage because it's like um
you know it's like you're stuck with
that forever like I see people that do
characters and I'm just like maybe you
should have thought about that 15 years
ago before you want to say like that's
who you are now what you put out there
forever will be yelled at you and
airports right you know I know what you
say like from doing the Rose I still
will be in the airport in something like
hey Conte and I'm like what that's how
they're greedy that's how they just
think they cuz I did the roast you know
like you really have to choose so I
wrote a book and I had a bunch of bad
things that happened to me or in the
book um people cut still come up to me
and they're like okay I'm like ya know
I'm getting on the plane I'm fine like
I'm good thank you
right I'm fine right you're like I'm
also struggling I'm like I'm late like I
can't do this fuck I'm in pre-check like
I just gotta like I've healed it I'm
good right now so I think for me it's
like what is what do you keep private
I hear you what about your marriage do
you talk about if they're yeah I mean if
there's if there's if there's I think
the more the humor is my my first
marriage because it was it's it's it's
AG more of extreme but do you know do
you choose your battles with when you
talk about her and how you talk about
her no I bet if I can't if I if I can't
make the shit funny after all the
fucking shit that we've been through you
know I have to be able to make it funny
like I talk about my wife now but it's
it's it's it's whatever's fuckin funny I
mean whatever comes out so I yeah I talk
about her like if she ever said like
don't talk about that no well she I've
been the other day I was doing this was
just like oh like I'm not a holiday
person what I'm not with the holidays
I'm not with the formality of it like
I'm a Grinchy motherfucker
well Jewish
this is a hot taste and my wife is a
very good cook but she fucked up a lot
of Thanksgiving and I was doing sin and
I was like y'all telling motherfuckers
because I need you I need you to learn a
lesson what I need you to learn that you
stovetop stuffing is a safe bet like you
don't have to every every dish doesn't
have to be a home run and you're not
fucking Martha Stewart nothing listen
you're not fucking Rachael Ray you're
not Bobby Flay okay just make the
stovetop stuffing like we're having a
small dinner here I want my fucking ham
and and it was supposed to be healthy
it's Thanksgiving it's there's nothing
that's supposed to be healthy about
Thanksgiving nothing you're supposed to
eat yourself into a Vaman estate you're
supposed to fall asleep and then you're
supposed to do it again and feel shame
and and and and and and so like she was
like you better not told me I was like
I'm gonna say that you can cook yeah but
this was a big failure and the fact that
you're resisting me and that you're
resist did your stuffing fell apart lady
only enjoys like stuffing is like loose
yo it's supposed to be like a solid
thing it's like I don't want to see all
the ingredients come I want that shit
like a fuckin piece of play-doh with
fucking stuff in the other day it's like
nah it's nothing solid yes it's like
mashed potatoes except for its if it
falls apart it's wrong that's I'm saying
and she was so fuckin had a shit eating
grin she was like is it good and I was
like and she could just tell from my
reaction I was like 9 she was like you
gotta put whatever so in that context
but my wife is she my wife and she so
yeah whatever but like my first marriage
has more things that I think are
attractive to stand-up comedy I see
there's there's more there's that you
were taken for everything you're not
everything but I mean you know there's
there's there's there's you know there's
altars there's you know there's child
support there's Alamo there's gay
alimony rights itself
so there's gay alimony what which is the
same as alimony like you don't get in
the Alamo
klm cuz my wife you know she was with
women you know she's so so like but
there's no concessions for that okay so
like Wow alimony Wow so so but yeah like
so go see Michael Rapaport he's in your
town I mean is a challenge do your kids
let you talking about him they have no
fucking choice they're there during the
like you know they're into some wild I
know the works you know that shit that I
was Rick's it all sorts of wild shit you
know like I got me there about about it
do you um know that there's porn that's
cartoons animated you know there's
podcast porn what does that mean it's
like it's like you know sexual podcasts
it's like it's like almost like
simulated sex peep it what do you tape
it this could be a whole like because
there's got to be like you know I think
you can jump in on cuz my phone stars or
something there's some of that
yes but it's like it's almost like pot
podcast porn Wow like is it people who
just like love Joe Rogan oh no no no
it's it's it's almost like um you know X
podcast
yeah that's wild but this is like or is
it to actually jerk off to actually uh
oh shit you know like what the fuck's
happening oh yeah don't do that
you know like is that good yeah it's
like it's like noise it's not video or
it could be also it could be also like
scripted like um scenes and stuff yeah
but could be scripted but it's not video
like podcast is for the ear so it could
be like picking you up and the whole
build up you can have a relationship
with you know you're getting off on it I
think people find it it's it's a new
thing it's a newer thing I read that on
the same site about the STDs okay yeah I
want to get in your cookies to Twitter
feeds we're in a similar Twitter feed
yeah I think so I get all my shit from
Twitter and then that takes you certain
there's a lot of porn on Twitter Joey
Diaz taught me that yeah I'm not with
that that that's me my kids are older
and I know they've seen it but I'm like
oh this shouldn't be like I report those
motherfuckers nicely
yeah man I'm not without you ain't a
snitch of Twitter with when it comes to
if I see like deep dicking file shit
like I'm not with that that's not
supposed to be like that shouldn't be
that should be a choice that I make and
and it's sir it shouldn't ambush you
your eight-year-old shouldn't come
across that's correct
I'm not with that well this is wild
because why is it on Twitter it's crazy
easy enough to like where you have to
Google in like let them find out yeah
I'm not with that I don't know I'm not
I'm not about that so I'm not consensual
bombarding I don't want it quite I came
whoa
I wasn't ready to jerk off right now
exactly this is like yo I'm in the car I
need to pull I gotta call Whitney be
like yo I'm gonna be 20 minutes late you
get bombarded on Twitter no but I do
there's this great TED talk Gayle
designs
Gayle Dean's TED talk about porn and
about why porn is so dangerous is
because young boys who right now are 10
12 years old you know in your day you
wanted to see boobies you go to your
dad's magazine or like a Sears catalog
or like a midnight blue on the channel J
in New York or or the newsstand you yeah
you look at the demand you would just
see boobies in a bud and it may be
vagina yeah but now if boys just want to
see boobies at 10 12 whatever you Google
naked woman and you're gonna get fisting
you're gonna get gesture I'm sayin
sign up to see that they didn't sign up
to see that and I didn't sign up to see
that and I'm a nasty motherfucker but I
want to do that on my own accord like I
like what I'm trying to go see some
highlights or the review of the Irishman
I don't know and I don't want to see
also I don't want to see a man and a
woman having sex and I don't want to see
two guys having sex I don't want to see
none of that shit are you trying to go
see some Kobe highlights from 99 yeah
yeah yeah fuck that I'm not with that Sh
I went on I'm not a prude and yes I'm a
report you nasty fucking dirty
motherfuckers I'm not with that shit I
rip I know I report him like you nope
I saw a couple of foul things like nah
this why am i I'm thinking that dude I
saw the phallus shit I've ever seen
because I was trending on pornhub don't
mean to brag
big you were I was I I got extorted and
oh I like my nipple was out and a bunch
of my guy friends really know you're
trending on pornhub
which was just like now I'd like every
time I got a text from one of my guy
friends about it I then got an insight
of the time of day they jerk off like it
was like oh like at 9:00 a.m. a bunch of
people were like we're trying I'm
pouring up and then like at like noon
all the comics started texting me right
like when they were I was like all right
I got it funny
I went on pornhub to check it out and
there was you know cuz you go to I don't
go to porn sites really so there was
there's all these videos around first of
all the fact that there's like popular
it's like why do you want to be jerking
off with the same shit other people it's
just not Star Wars popular is just so
weird to me like I want to jerk off with
everyone else
funny like this is pop it's just like
and I went on and there was a I got
really obsessed with the anime porn yes
I just thought that was just funny the
idea that someone's like I've seen all
the humans like I'm only get off on yeah
like you know just how far gone you must
be I guess or maybe it's like maybe
there's something good about it maybe
it's like you know cuz a lot of porn is
you're like is this a crime there's
something kind of nice about it not
being a human involved you don't see
like weird bruises or like weird like
shit in the background but I saw a video
the camera was inside the woman's butt
and the dick was coming at the camera
from in her but I would like to see it
was like a colonoscopy video it was from
the outside I was like I they looked at
like I didn't know shit was happening it
looked like a camera was shooting out
the camera was in her butthole
oh and the penis was coming at the
camera Wow it was around that's some
stuff to be Steven Spielberg she I
thought it was like tonsils like it was
like the inside and I just like I didn't
understand and then I clicked on it I
was like ah now my algorithm is so
jacked up that I clicked on it but it
was like they put a camera inside you
now in your body yeah like it's enough I
saw some gay porn that I got on Twitter
that fucked me up man I was like oh this
is like some other shit this is some way
or the shit sometimes when women's butt
holes are too stretched out I get really
upset I'm not with that shit either like
I don't understand how they go
through the world like yeah when you're
not freaking off it doesn't there's no
way that's gonna bounce back I hear you
you know to me I hear there's no way
this can be worth this financial I know
numbers add I hear you you know like
when you get a piercing in the hole
doesn't close up like I know how skin
works I know how skin elasticity works
I'm gonna get you out of here but there
are a couple questions asked you that
people ask from the internet first I
want to ask you what we ask everyone is
you've been rich for enough time what
have you spent money on that like works
that were like what's the bet like that
you know sometimes you buy things you're
like well that didn't do it like I
bought a shirt I thought that was like
diamonds for my wife that should work
those are listen really good answer
whose work see I love those work I
suggest jewelry because if she's yelling
at you just like I don't even do they
work
i immense work yep I agree jewelry does
work and you know it's kind of a cliche
but it works it works you asked me about
function that functional spending I
don't mean this in a gold-digger way
this is not women like it but here's why
that's and it's a loner strong women
strong women like it strong like it
everyone like that women like jewelry
cuz to me it's an investment you've
invested in me
you spent money on something valuable I
know I feel that's not what you like you
just like the chocolate chip cookie or
like a great California and I like it
because other people know I'm taken
that's I don't even I didn't think about
that yes but but that that works you
know and it's just sort of it when I'm
like it makes me think twice about
sending that shitty text I'm like but
the bracelet it were does a hundred
percent maybe I'm a 50s housewife or
some shit but I like it yes I'm like he
wouldn't to spend this money he
obviously didn't mean it right it's like
it helps me talk myself off a ledge
sometimes when I find myself being
arrested right you know yes yes that's
what great and that that would be the
one answer and then a couple people want
to ask about a typical we haven't really
got to it you know I I binge to this
show when I was sick last year and I
cried every episode I love I love doing
the show and and you know I've done so
much shit as an actor
yeah and I say shit I mean stuff and and
and you know the response of the show
has been more than oh I just liked the
show or oh the shows funny or oh that's
so crazy or that movie so like the the
response from fans has been so emotional
and and and and that's not something you
could predict a plan and and and and you
know like I'm not like you know I'm not
here for for that but the resident the
way it resonated with people has it's
it's like I'm like damn that's that's
dope
it is like the closest thing I can I
hope this isn't I love this it's like a
really it's like a smarter hit it almost
has like a Wonder Years someone else
said someone say that way like I'm so I
care for me to watch TV you probably -
all I do is go like my audition for that
or uh I know him he's an asshole like
it's so hard for me to live right get
engrossed in a show yeah give a shit
yeah I'm just like oh that's a good
story like I could have paid off more
and then I you know I watch TV shows oh
my god eighty are like all I do acted by
title shit I for the first time in so
long felt like I was just like a fan
watching a TV show yeah it's a simple
show simple characters and it's just a
sweet show and it's funny and you know
and I love playing the part and and and
the kid you know the characters so I'm
not saying unlike you but I know a side
of you that like breaks my heart
yeah yeah yeah like it that character
like breaks my heart
I appreciate it you know it's and it's
it's it's it's a fun it's a fun part to
play like I'll be honest I don't have
that much fun playing the part because
the character is so sort of emotionally
yeah repressed so sometimes I'm like I
don't wanna fucking you know like I feel
like I just I wanna you know like yeah
you know because I you know and there is
pain in it and and you know like for me
to get it and I'm not like one of these
method actors all but like it just stick
with you you know like that that going
into those colors but I do shows dope
and it's fun show and I'm just so happy
that you know we've been doing it three
years and hopefully we'll do another
season and I think that it now
not I never but I think it at a time
where no one really wants to talk about
how life might be hard for some men
sometimes there's something about it
that just made me go like oh my god it
must be hard to be a dad right times and
like especially because you might not
have like the vocabulary or it's not
socially accepting a parent is not an
easy thing know and being a parent is
you know like I'm terrified and and for
women to like you know you're supposed
to put on a happy face and it's the love
of my life that's just bullshit yeah
yeah yeah yeah you you might come to
that and you might have that also but
there's many other things that
particularly you know mothers are gonna
go through and fathers are gonna go
through like the shit ain't all fuckin
Brady Bunch and and and and and you know
from my own experience it shit's fucking
it's a it's a challenge so you know when
I think that's articulated in things I
think it's it's good because you know
especially with women you know you're
supposed to be like you know this is the
love of my life and it's changed my life
it might not have changed your fuckin
life make you a bad women and you know
some women um you know they um you know
I think it's okay for some women be like
I don't want kids you know like we're
you know what kind of woman you know I'm
the kind of woman who doesn't want kids
yeah they'll make me you know yeah I
think there's a shame in that when women
say I don't want kids and you know
you're supposed to want kids
that's something wrong with you so you
know and not that that it doesn't go
that far into but I in it I just think
there when there's that honesty about
parenting I think it's good and also I
do I don't see as many shows that as
someone who in my 20s I cheated a lot
and no one talks did you really yes it
just was that's how it was and right I
just might if you don't know where you
do my thing was I'm codependent no more
any more oh yeah you read that I know
that boy is a good boy basically you
know cuz I used to be so afraid of
hurting someone's feelings I didn't want
to break up with them so I would just
start dating someone else and assume
they would like figure it out and be
like oh yeah like I just was I couldn't
break up with people right you know like
I couldn't be direct and clear with
people so I was right right right then I
didn't like I just was like didn't have
enough self-esteem or confidence I was
just like sloppy about it I now
how destructive and selfish that was but
at the time I was like no I just don't
want to be mean right you know so I'll
just you know but that's why you
shouldn't be in deep relationships when
you're that young two hundred percent I
had no idea who I was and I didn't yet
have the tools to be able to articulate
to somebody right now and then I am just
seeing that just because I do think that
we really want to write stories about
how all men do is cheat right women are
better cheaters women are better
cheaters and and get sometimes more
emotionally sometimes there's emotional
Affairs that aren't even said right but
you know so I just like really
appreciate that because I have so many
girlfriends that are going through that
right now where the woman cheated and
there's too much shame to talk about it
they want you know it's just like this
weird thing we have a template name some
of the people that are cheating they do
not talk that much shit all right all
right that uh a lot of people want to
know about your recent interest in the
Housewives love it love it can I tell
you something you know what I love this
so much because because I cannot stand
now that people that call themselves
feminists want to say that the
housewives aren't feminists or they're
bad for women shut up get the fuck out
of here I don't like this thing where
it's shut your mouth in order to be a
strong woman you have to be strong the
way I what does that mean and does that
mean you shouldn't cook dinner for your
husband I don't like to cook somebody's
gonna have to cook can I tell you
something that's another that was
another thing I was saying about my wife
when I was saying about the tape things
go because I was like she likes my wife
likes to cook yeah you know I'm injured
you're not allowed to like to cook
anymore no no you know here's what I
should cook but you don't want me
cooking I was talking to Bill burr about
to say the day some of the richest women
in the world are professional chefs
celebrity chefs right Rachael Ray's not
a feminist is that what you're trying to
tell me Martha Stewart a feminist listen
motherfucker way she chose to make her
man I ain't good at cooking yeah and and
and and and and she likes cooking I
don't like being in there yeah so you
could just st. you know however you want
to wrap your head around it you wrap
your fucking head around it now some
things feel like the stuffing the
stuffing was a failure all right as a
woman were allowed to be flawed with
logic that was a disappointment for me
is that you should have just got the $9
box of stove top kept it fucking me I go
that is such a healthy converse is like
the traditional gender
if a woman chooses to be in a
traditional gender role that is her
choice like Dan Bilzerian blocked me on
Instagram word this is that he's my
LeBron
he's my truck so he blot we I go after
him on Instagram because he always
abuses animals at his parties he has
like you know electrocuted bears and
shit at his Tigers at his parties and
stuff but I never go after him for the
women at his parties and people always
like well why aren't you attacking him
because he objectifies women I'm like
like if women want to be in bathing
suits at his party that's their choice
I'm not gonna call them whores right I'm
not gonna call them sluts when I was 25
if some rich guy invited me to his party
for $1,000 I would do it that would have
been a great way to make money back
right like I'm not gonna judge that you
know I are gonna judge how women choose
to make their money I hear you and that
they just might be having their young
that's right they're you know they're
doing their thing let them let them rock
who gives a shit yeah but I think the
the housewives I appreciate that you're
into this crazy and no like feminist I
fuck with the housewife whore favorite
city pride in New York Riaz was in New
York and then Atlanta yeah those are my
but I mean I fuck with Lana Jersey
Potomac Potomac Potomac Thome yeah I
don't say right girl there's a woman
that was on the first season who was my
first modeling agent her name was Linda
or galician she was on the first season
of Potomac pochamma I know I don't
what is Potomac it's happening I don't
know then I don't know this place helmet
man Tomac is that way DC yeah from DC
means nothing that's driven to high
school for Petone Potomac you don't
watch Real Housewives of Potomac
any other pet peeves that are bothering
you right now shit
I mean that's driving all the way out
here doing podcasts although I do think
you should do one last pocket bitch sesh
which is about that I've done okay like
two or three times okay so that's your
thing and then why do people everyone
wants to ask about you and Stern what
about that buoy I don't know people so
cuz I cuz I'm on there and I talk shit
okay a lot of people seem to think that
oh and what is happening with the cat
that got banned you're viewed a video of
a cat get banned it's not worth
discussing I did a video that went super
duper extra viral a funny video with a
cat yeah
and then I think because of the cursing
in it that it got taken off but Oh
leaving all the shadow banning stuff I
think that's real yeah yeah what's
Shadow Man but because I uploaded a
photo of my boob and I violated the
terms and then I wasn't searchable for a
couple days remember and then he took
you off and then basically I've been
shadow being on Instagram those Fox it
basically just means that it was harder
to search you right and they fuck with
you and followers you think that they're
manually doing it they're doing
something I know for cuz I met I met
with some people at Instagram and they
told me like they do that shit we're
watching you and we're gonna be punitive
a shadow banning is real and and and
they slow down you're sort of you know
growth the ability to like a tag you and
stuff yeah yes yes yes if they think
that you're saying some Incendia but I
don't say these I just say fuck a lot
but why would that get you shadow I say
fuck a lot and and then you know like it
could be conceived as bullying when I
make fun of Trump Oh bullying that shit
okay yeah bullying the bully are you
letting people text you yet do you not
yet I'm not set up eight one eight two
three nine seven do you like that Evan
yeah I'm super into it cuz you're on
your phone just I love it I love it
because you can send the best thing
about it you actually should do it
because you know my least favorite thing
is when I'm going to Philadelphia and I
post on my main feat Philadelphia most
people that follow me aren't from
Philadelphia you don't mean and you're
blowing up your grid with just specific
cities so what you can do is I can text
euro in my location only by location
only text that people and that's a
that's what that's what I'm interesting
I mean that's what you want to do right
it goes right to it because most people
also don't see my biggest problem then
surrounds most people don't see your
post because the algorithm do you know
Lauren Hill was at the Hollywood Bowl
I'm still ranting about this no Lauren
Hill was at the Hollywood Bowl I had no
idea what do you really want to see
Lauren hell yes yes this is infamous for
doing terrible shows well late just
doing the songs that you want to hear
and how you want to hear that sorry III
fuck with Lauren but it's been 20 years
since your last record yeah and I've
seen you a handful of times and it
hasn't been good once and I would never
pay money to see or I would never take a
VIP ticket to go see Laurens it's a
wasted
these are at the club nokia apparently
in her contract if she's a minute late
she doesn't get into the money at this
point so she came out at like 11:59 the
show was at 8:00 people started leaving
at 11:00 and there were like I had
babysitters half of us you left there on
that and then she came out and then
there nope the hits she was singing more
like reggae yeah nope and no one could
see now nope
hell no give a fuck could I also have
respecting the customers sorry I need
that shit so many times this way and
like me sorry it up we'll make a new
song Lauryn Hill you want you do that
why don't you instead of switching up
the songs that we want here why don't
you do the songs that we want to hear
the way we want to hear and why don't
you come up with a new songs you haven't
made a new song in 20 years
oh no you say that I'm paying customer
to see you you haven't put on your shows
are fucked up you're late and you
haven't put out a new banger or I don't
even think an attempt at a new song and
I we're at 20 years so the mis-education
is dope and you know so is you know
Abbey Road we're talking about like a
long time ago it's sorry
fucking Baltimore McGoo bees have you
performed you've know all these great
venue McGoo bees incredible venue it's
like a perfect little theatre can't wait
and my special there the night before
Boston 27 to 29 yup
you're gonna do well in Boston I hope
December 27 to 29
I hope Boston people like you or that
yeah we get along I think you know they
like to break balls up will be fun but
you're Michael Rapaport comedy calm yep
Michael Rapaport comedy dot-com no
atypical binge this you're gonna you're
just black out your day cuz only a
sociopath would not be able to watch the
entire like you can't watch just one
episode of the show I appreciate if
you're gonna fall in love I don't know
what anything else you want to plug shit
that's in this podcast I know not weird
you think I came out here dude no I know
because I've done a couple of Pi I did
three podcast this week what this why
I'm said I told him I said let's do it
before do it before no no no I'm at my
Lyme disease no no
note I said do it before the end of the
year cuz next year that's right you're
out but before the father once you did
this it don't matter that you mean this
week yeah this way you don't matter it
don't matter but they were there were
favors and we're not doing that any no
no no those days are over the score
cards clean I've done enough no I know
I'll try later and I have my own shit
that's right and my own pockets I very
rarely have guests yeah so I'll do I
always do Rogen always do Rogen I
haven't done is Hipparchus yet oh really
Oh that'll be good I'll be good for you
got a hydrate you're there for a while
yeah I'm not doing that either you know
three hours shit yeah that shit halfway
through you're like I gotta go pee but
you're you know we're talking about
neurology and wolfs I'd only want
haven't done okay so I don't know what
do you say at the end of your podcast
you're the king I say I'm out teach me I
say I say III have a very specific day I
just say if I would say thank you for
having me oh thank you for being here
and uh oh thanks for the hospitality and
shit that's it
I appreciate you driving all the way out
here and I appreciate you will always
have a place in my heart for pushing me
to do stands and I'm done that's it
[Music]